we've been using the m1 macbook pro
quite extensively for over a month now
and i'm finally ready to gather all of
my thoughts and conclusions
into a long term review and the way i
want to do it is to look at the general
consensus about the transition to apple
silicon
before apple actually revealed them and
then look at the reality of the m1
macbook pro
after just one month so brace yourselves
because this is about to be the most
comprehensive review you've probably
seen
way back in june and july shortly after
apple's announcement
a lot of people were doubting this
transition one user said that we would
have to wait at least
two years before the new chip would be a
good option
another one said in no way will the r
mac have both more power and more
battery life
if you're into programming i would 100
percent buy an
intel mac versus wait for arm i don't
think they'll have a powerful
macbook pro level processor until 2022.
just look at all of those negative
comments about the transition
but wait it gets even worse when we take
a look
at the gaming outlook gaming is coming
but it won't be anything but mobile
games
unless a real dedicated gpu is on board
rest in peace gaming on a mac machine
macbooks won't get aaa games our macs
will not be real computers reading those
comments today is hilarious
because as we all know they were
completely
wrong and i'll show you guys just how
wrong they were
in just a couple of minutes so now let's
get into the reality
of the m1 macbook pro after just one
month
and i'm going to be focusing on
answering the three main doubts about
the apple silicon transition
the m1 max having weak performance
the software transition being incredibly
bumpy
especially for x86 apps and lastly
apple silicon being the death of aaa
gaming
on the mac but before i get into that i
want to quickly cover
the actual macbook pro itself in terms
of the design
it's basically the same as it was before
still
being more premium thin and light than a
lot of other laptops
the new magic keyboard is amazing with
no reliability
issues like we had with the butterfly
keyboard the speakers continue to blow
away
every other windows laptop out there the
new studio quality microphones
sound really good and natural and the
new image signal processor in the m1
chip
has actually greatly improved the webcam
quality
even though it's 720p yes it's not the
1080p webcam that we were hoping for
but look at how it compares to the
latest webcam from the dell xps
it destroys it and the force touch
trackpad is still
hands down the best trackpad ever made
now while we didn't get the redesign
that we were hoping for
it still looks great with a 13 inch
display
that's still on par with even the latest
windows laptops
like the xps 13. and keep in mind that
next year's
14 inch macbook pro will have a full
redesign with a new mini led display
which will be class leading in every way
it's also gonna have an
even better chip which i believe is
gonna blow
people's minds but for now let's answer
the first doubt that people had
before the m1 max were revealed and
that's the performance
to do this i'm going to show off some of
our results from our m1 macbook pro
versus 16 inch base macbook pro
comparison video
in terms of geekbench 5 cpu test the m1
absolutely blew it away especially in
single core performance
and even in cinebench r23 which tests
throttling over a 10 minute test
the m1 was actually faster for graphics
the m1s integrated gpu
was performing surprisingly close to the
dedicated 5300m
in the 16 inch even in the gfx bench
gaming benchmark
the 16 inch was only 12 faster
but here's the kicker the m1 gpu
was only using 5.6 watts
while the 5300 m was using a massive
45 watts now moving on to some more
tests i'm also going to add in some of
the other intel macs that we tested
for some extra context in the logic pro
stress test
the m1 absolutely destroyed the previous
intel macbook pro
and was surprisingly not too far behind
the latest 8 core
imac but by far the biggest improvement
that we saw
was in our max tech xcode benchmark with
the m1 max
outperforming our 15 000 mac pro
which we did not expect at all and
making it even more crazy
we tested lightroom classic which was
running under rosetta 2.
the m1 macbook pro finished the export
test
faster than the 16 inch which basically
nobody was expecting when apple
announced the transition
and then moving on to final cut pro the
m1 beat the 16-inch by around
30 seconds in our 4k 5-minute export
test
and it was only around 5 seconds slower
than the 8 core imac
and the best part is that the m1 max are
able to play back
very tough canon r5 footage with no
issues while even our mac pro
can't handle it due to having older
hardware decoders and in terms of
transcoding speed
the m1 max blow away every single intel
mac
now here's my favorite part after about
three and a half
hours of shooting that m1 versus 16 inch
comparison video
the 16 inch was left with 3
battery life and the m1 had
67 battery life which is absolutely
mind blowing so we're not only getting
much better performance than even
a base 16-inch macbook pro but we're
also getting
many times better battery life as well
and that's been the general consensus
with new owners of m1 max many of them
are absolutely blown away by the battery
life
and to make it even better you can
hardly ever hear the fan
on the m1 macbook pro while the 16-inch
has two of them and they were blaring
for many of the tests in that video and
if you're wondering why
here's an absolute shocker the m1 pro
cpu
took only 13 watts of power under
full sustained load compared to 67 watts
on the 16 inch so in reality it makes
total sense
why the fan on the m1 rarely ever gets
loud
now this also gives the m1 max a huge
advantage over windows laptops
since you can use it unplugged and get
full performance
while many other laptops like the dell
xps slow
down significantly in the interest of
saving battery life
making it even more interesting we did a
ram stress test between the 16 gig
m1 macbook pro and the 16 gig dell xps
13
and to our surprise the m1 wouldn't
budge
we ran a bunch of tasks in the
background and then
ran our lightroom export test which is
hugely dependent on ram
and as you can see the m1 mac barely
slowed down while the xbs took almost
twice as long to finish the export so
this shows that apple's unified memory
is incredibly efficient and it almost
acts like it has more ram than it
actually does
so we've been recommending most people
to simply get the eight gigabyte model
unless you know that you really need 16.
this was actually a hugely controversial
issue
because people were saying that the swap
memory would
damage the ssd even in the span of just
a few months
but that's really misleading swap memory
didn't magically appear with m1 max
apple's been doing this for years and
even windows computers do this as well
if this was a huge deal then older
macbooks would have major ssd issues
but they've proven to be incredibly
reliable
and so will the m1 max now let's get
into the second doubt that people had
before the m1 max were released and
that's software support
rosetta 2 has proven to run almost every
x86
app that most people use right out of
the gate
and it's only been getting better as mac
os big sur
has been getting updated over the past
month the biggest
issues people are still having is with
certain plugins
like motion vfx for final cut pro which
do have to get updated to apple silicon
but other than that everything runs
impressively fast
iphone and ipad apps are now running
very well
with full screen support so there are no
issues with that
but i've been absolutely blown away at
the speed at which developers
are updating apps for apple silicon
after just a month
microsoft's full office suite has been
updated with
native apple silicon support firefox
chrome
and microsoft edge have already been
updated with full support for m1 max
along with visual studio code python
intellij idea adobe lightroom
and both docker and parallel 16
are now getting their first tech
previews these professional apps are
getting updated
much sooner than i thought they would
and it's starting to feel like this is
causing more and more pressure
on other developers to update their apps
for apple silicon
especially since the performance is so
promising
this is extremely exciting because at
this rate
a lot of the most popular apps should
have native apple silicon support
by the time we get the next wave of
higher end max
next year so all of the previous doubts
about the transition being bumpy
in terms of the software for the first
couple of years are completely
wrong because it's only been one month
and the software support is good enough
right now that most people can
upgrade without any issues so hats off
to apple
and many developers for pulling that off
in such a short time
one of the major controversies
surrounding the m1 macbooks
was the very limited display support but
we've already seen users running six
displays
off of an m1 mac using hubs adapters and
special software someone else was able
to get a 4k
display running at 144hz and with hdr
enabled
at the same time using an external hub
so those who require
better display support can get more
displays running
if they really need to but in reality
most people buying an entry-level
macbook
don't even use one external display in
the first place
and now let's move on to answering the
final doubt about the apple silicon
transition
and that's people believing that aaa
gaming on the mac
is going away but before i get into how
impressive the gaming support has been
in just the first month of the very
first weakest apple silicon mac
chip that will ever be made i want to
give you guys some context
in the past 13-inch intel macbooks in
the mac
mini required an egpu to get decent
gaming performance
which is another 700 on top
of buying the mac itself and the fans
would always be crazy loud as well i
even tested the 2020 intel macbook air
with an egpu and the performance was
absolutely terrible
because the cpu was literally at 100
degrees celsius
the entire time even though the powerful
egpu
was taking care of the graphics load so
aaa gaming was basically impossible on a
macbook air
and for the macbook pro and mac mini an
egpu was an
absolute must the main advantage was
boot camp support for playing windows
games
which the m1 max unfortunately don't
have anymore
and that's mainly what led to comments
saying
rest in peace gaming on a mac machine
but thankfully
they're dead wrong after people actually
got their hands on these new m1 max
it's been the complete opposite i'm
gonna take a bold stance and say that
the m1 chip
is the beginning of the revival of
aaa gaming on the mac an entire
community has been thriving
on the mac gaming subreddit where people
are sharing their excitement
for playing games on m1 max people are
now using rosetta to get very impressive
performance
in games like black ops 3 baldur's gate
3
hades and civilization 6 on a macbook
air
with no throttling issues at all i
myself was able to play games like
minecraft
cs go diablo 3 fortnite
and league of legends using rosetta with
better performance than i ever
expected and the fans barely went above
idol
sitting at around 2000 rpm going even
further
users have been using crossover 20 which
installs and emulates windows apps and
games on the mac
and they're getting awesome performance
in games like resident evil 3
age of empires 2 rocket league metro
exodus
and much more i myself used crossover to
play witcher 3
which is the number one search result
when you google
best aaa games and i was able to get
great performance
at slightly higher than 1080p resolution
on top of that
people have been enjoying ipad games on
their macbooks
like tropico one user was even able to
run both grand theft auto 3
and vice city at the same time i
personally ran
four ipad games at once being able to
easily switch between them
and then take one game into full screen
mode with
no issues and even running 4 games
the m1 didn't break a sweat other users
on reddit have also started using
emulators
to play games like zelda ocarina of time
new super mario brothers
and mario kart with better than expected
performance
i even used the fanless 7 core macbook
air to play world of warcraft
which is currently the only aaa game
which is fully updated for apple silicon
and i was able to get a minimum of 60fps
in dungeons with the graphics settings
turned down
and to my surprise the cpu temps were
incredibly cool
even without a fan showing just how
promising the future of mac gaming can
be
when more games come with apple silicon
support in the future
like the game studio feral games which
will support
m series chips for every future game
they make
so the fact of the matter is that most
if not all of the doubt surrounding
gaming on apple silicon max
is basically gone and now the comments
have changed
here's a reddit post where someone was
playing an ipad game on an m1 mac in
full screen
someone asked if this is only possible
on m1 max
and when he got the answer yes he
replied
sad there's a video of someone playing
fallout 4 using crossover on the m1
macbook air
and one of the comments said wow on a
macbook air
that smooth someone else made a post
saying i just got
my m1 macbook air which game should i
try first
this is quite ironic because nobody has
ever
said that about an intel macbook air and
it's the complete
opposite of what people were thinking
just two months ago
now the biggest drawback of the m1 max
still remains
the lack of bootcamp support because the
current version of crossover
can't even run some games like call of
duty warzone
and cyberpunk 2077 but thankfully
there's a silver lining people have
already figured out ways to run windows
on m1 max
using qemu and surprisingly
it runs much faster than microsoft's own
surface pro
x which is hilarious and others are now
showing off
games like maplestory running using this
method
but making it even better parallel 16
for m1 max is now finally available
through the windows insider program and
the performance is
very promising martin nobel ran
geekbench 5 using parallels
and he got 1475 for the single core and
5093 for the multi-core
which is close to intel's 11th gen i7
cpu
in the latest dell xps 13. and after
only two days one user showed off
parallels gameplay on his base
m1 macbook air playing games like far
cry 3 at an average of 45
fps rocket league at around 50 to 70 fps
and track mania turbo at 70 to 90 fps
others were even able to get games like
half-life 2
to run with great looking frame rates
along with counter-strike source
assassin's creed and elite dangerous
getting 50 to 60 fps on high settings
this is extremely impressive because
it's not just parallels running
but windows is also emulating these
x64 games at the same time
and we're actually getting playable
performance
and all of this has happened within the
first
month since these new m1 max have been
released
now the funny thing is that when i made
that video back in july about apple
silicon
bringing aaa gaming to the mac i was
honestly thinking that it would take
maybe
one or two years after the first max
came out
to finally start seeing that happen but
the
m1 max are literally doing this right
now
after just one month the only thing
holding them back is the graphics
performance
which can't keep up with higher end
dedicated graphics
chips but for having integrated graphics
the gaming performance we're getting
with the m1 max is
already super impressive and next year
we're expecting
new m1x max to come with around 16
gpu cores with potentially twice the
graphics performance
of these m1 max and at that point
those macs will be running aaa games at
high
settings with excellent frame rates less
than one year
after the switch to apple silicon one
reddit user
made a post saying that macs are poised
to become
the number one platform for aaa gaming
and it's crazy that this could actually
become a reality
thanks to apple silicon so with
everything that i discussed in this
review
it's clear that apple's very first m1
max
are blowing away the initial doubts and
expectations
in basically every way and i'm willing
to bet that when next year's higher end
max get released
the rest of the industry is going to
panic
macbooks will not only be leading every
single battery life comparison chart
but every single performance chart as
well because of this
windows laptop makers will be putting
immense pressure on
intel and amd to get high-performance
arm-based chips
into laptops as soon as possible
qualcomm and samsung will enter the
laptop game
thanks to their head start and arm-based
chips and
everyone is going to be putting pressure
on microsoft to heavily invest
into improving the arm version of
windows
in fact microsoft is reportedly
developing
their own arm-based chips for their
servers
and surface pcs likely in reaction to
apple's success
with their very first m1 max what we are
witnessing right now
is the beginning of a personal computing
revolution
the likes of which we haven't seen in
many years
we just haven't realized it yet so there
you guys go
that was my review of the m1 macbook pro
and if you enjoyed it go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe
and check out one of those two videos
right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one